congratulations i've been talking to
some of the other
you know people and they were all blown
away i mean they mentioned you guys
tonight as some of the
being blown away
how how
are you right now
um
personally for me i'm feeling really
happy and excited that we did that
and yeah i'm really proud of us
excited excited grateful to you know to
our peers for acknowledging you know i
think yes slowly it's it's been
one of the best things about the show is
the camaraderie that's built between the
celebrities
uh and and they're building that you
know week three you don't want to see
anybody go so it's it's crushing to see
anybody eliminated but we're also
rooting off you know rooting for each
other so
you know we appreciate them appreciating
our performance
one of the things that bruno said i
think was bruno said we're seeing you
olivia transform right in front of our
eyes do you feel that way
i think so i don't even know what i feel
right now um i definitely feel like this
whole experience has made me
grow as a person in a really cheesy
cliche way i know that's probably like
said a lot but i really do mean it it's
like when you put your all into
something and you really are working
every single day hours on end to try and
do something semi decent it's like
really exciting when it's
the time and it happens and you get
great feedback so
i'm super super grateful and excited
um
have you seen her transform mal
yes
yes no
no no i've seen it but
you know i
almost immediately saw that she can do
it
and i was then excited for you know that
element of surprise
you know surprising the world surprising
the cast
and and it didn't happen right away but
it happened slowly and i i want to
continue to do that i want to you know
scores aside it was beautiful to hear
the judges give us good feedback but i
just want to continue to
surprise ourselves our goal is to have a
good you know the
the last dance to be our best dance
and uh they cut away to the audience at
one point and it said olivia's family so
how how did it feel to have your family
here tonight and who was here
my big sister
she looked i mean i went oh my god they
look a lot alike
yes we're little twins yeah she's uh
we're super close in age she's only 12
months 12 days older than me
so
first of all she's like my best friend
on like built-in best friend obviously
she's forced to like me because she's my
older sister
but it means everything to have her
there and she comes every single week
she is made about me to be here as long
as i am and to show up and yeah it
brings a lot of comfort
and
what have you learned about yourself in
these last three weeks
for me i think what i've learned the
most about myself is that i have a lot
more patience for myself than i ever
thought i did
so uh just not being so hard on myself
and knowing that it's gonna turn out
when it comes like to the live show on
monday
i'll have the steps because really i
mean hopefully but really in the
beginning of the weeks it's like the
toughest part like tomorrow and
wednesday and thursday will be the most
challenging i think you really have to
soak it in and learn it and then you get
frustrated when you don't get it and i
think
again
i don't think she has much choice
also you know you quit along the way
because
you get you know you're hard on yourself
and you don't have somebody there that's
not giving you a chance to quit you know
you could be harder to sell but we're
still going to keep going right
you know i think she's seen that if you
just keep going
you know it's going to lead to a better
place and it's like led us to tonight
and this being um
you know
britney knight
what what did that mean to you to i mean
what would you want to say to brittany
after that performance
great song great so thank you for making
that song no i think she's such an icon
she's
if i could say anything to her i would
just say like
wow you're super strong and
inspirational and
it was an honor to do something to
yeah to you create it it's insane
and that's for a picture
yes
and now you've got two song two dances
to learn next for next week
is that yeah
what what's that going to be like it's
scary
it's really scary uh
i don't know how it's gonna go i guess
i'll find out starting tomorrow but
i'm really also excited because i'm
having so much fun and i'm just really
grateful for the experience so the fact
that we get to double up and
to spend even more time with you it's
just an honor
okay now that you're spending so much
time together are there arguments or
disagreements or do you just listen to
everything he says
i honestly know nobody listens to
anything anybody says
we work together
you know
she's she has a voice in the room you
know she's empowered in the room it's
not about what i
say all the time
but i think it's important for me to be
available to her for whatever she needs
you know and so we work together and i i
i share everything with her and she has
final say on
everything that we do her hair her dress
her songs
everything that we do creatively on the
show together yeah it really does feel
like a good team bond so it's really
great
all right well thank you so much for
spending a little time with et canada
and i look forward to next week thank
you thank you